Kostas we'll be talking about embeddings
today
and I have to warn you this is not the
Python talk is mostly mouths so if you
want to leave just I can live with that
chick so yeah I mean the discussion will
be focusing around not only what to work
most of the people I know the romantics
I'm mostly using birth defect or some
reason most probably because it's fast
and it was the first one that was
exciting that introduced some years back
five six years back so how many of you
have you do you know who that you know
work like cool how many of you you have
changed a model yourself awesome glove
okay
first text start spaced around the book
no so you see like the distribution of
things how does essentially a shop
slides in a bit
what the beddings are mappings from
words two-dimensional vectors so say you
have this this actual numbers come from
a globe model the two hundred
dimensional globe model and the machine
the world machine is mapped to this kind
of vector and the world itself
intelligence to that vector why we were
doing that we'll be discussing that in a
bit and let's go
yeah what sorry
yep oh come on sorry
because it's kind of like not so
convenient to write math on PowerPoint
okay cool so we'll be discussing we'll
be doing a novelty of waterbending
models and their properties
we'll be discussing what updates oh and
where they are so important there are
several models in the nation the most
common of them were to vet with two
variations globe passed X star space
around the world and there are even more
poincare bendixson for hierarchical
models which I don't even touch there
are several ways and literature around
that and how do we actually create a
bendix for combination of objects but
let's get started
why were the Bendix so I mean you must
probably know that the typical world the
typical text representation for like
words in documents is one hot encoding
so have a huge vector with Dement
dimensionality of our vocabulary
where every everywhere zero except the
position of the world have one this
visitation is very cool but has also
some some issues around that if we were
to measure some sort of distance between
words in the vocabulary with one hot
vocabulary we'll be having the same
distance between all words with any
given distance measure or similarity
measure it would be very very nice to
have a property that will map distance
of similar words in semantics very very
close in the time in the dimensional
space from a geometrical point of view
and third we would like to have a
compact representation time nationality
because if you have say vocabulary word
fit in a modern on Wikipedia or the web
we can have hundreds of millions of
words and that's not not
convenient for computational reasons and
ideally there's a thing called word
analysis I would like to have us a
narrative representation that we can
actually turn semantics into linear
algebra right so given the vector
King King if we subtract the vector man
and add the vector woman we'll be
getting something which is really really
close to the world through the word
Queen this comes from the word factor
the quarterback paper back in 2013 and I
think it's pretty much everywhere in
every single NLP paper these days or
embedded spider all this concept are
coming around but the theory behind all
this work is what we call the
distributional hypothesis with origins
back in 54 1954 by Harris and validation
oblong says that claims that the words
that occur similar contexts tend to have
similar meanings which is kind of
obvious but it's a very good place stuff
in a more poetic statement you shall
know a word by the company it keeps
which is again super nice one I like
that so what's Devon okay here comes
moths from distributional from the
traditional hypothesis were jumping to
probabilistic language statistical
language models because we're
essentially trying to model the
probability of a word that will appear
after another world and in the sense of
like the company of quartz
distributional setting there are several
methods to do to learn statistical
language model from road text but most
of them actually all of them have a
common problem there will be always
sequences in natural language which you
don't have in your training course so
you cannot assign probabilities 0 the
seconds right so if you have like for
example power
statistical language motives are heavily
used in voice recognition what will be
saying next Chevy depends on would have
said already
but at some points that can they can be
sequences of world never uttered before
or never appear appeared in in our
training course and we cannot assign
zero probability zero probability will
crush our models we don't want that so
the core idea but in 2003 by Benjamin
Sisko around break-in is that can we use
a neural net to approximate this
probability distribution so statistical
engines model then is defined as the
probable conditional probability of the
next court given the previous ones we're
doing some simplification and disregard
most of the world keeping a window of n
words the Engram model and then we use a
neural net to proximate that model and
we're getting back in the hidden layers
an approximation of what color
vocabularies over by treating dimension
of the hidden layer first representation
done that was very interesting
aha there's a very interesting applauds
model slow because the last layer of the
neural net is a soft marks over several
million were things very slow string
sorry
it's really oh okay cool
I changed not to sleep but the doors are
interfere yeah
so softmax over several hundreds of
millions worth slow first model technic
two or three days to Train fast-forward
to get 20 years later consuming 2013
Michelob I don't being at Google at the
time introduced Hoover what the vectra's
essentially is just its gamer this all
the models are not the planning models
this especially what - that is not a
development model is a silo log linear
model
so then tradition would back with two
variations SIBO and the program will be
discussing little bit about that later
and become with several hugs to improve
performance negative sampling
hierarchical softmax a synchronous the
past gradient and send modifications on
the loss function and so on so forth it
rains really fast like several hundred
million machines like less than half an
hour and can also exploit pilot and can
be used all you the course in Gilmer
same cool and also comes with neatly
property tink - mine plus woman a girl
screen so yeah people but really really
excited
see Bo
like I said whatever comes into
architectures RC bo with this
essentially continuous back of wards so
in the optimal things we were trying to
predict next world like the neural net
tries to predict next word given context
right so you have the context every like
drawing on the left is essentially one
whole decoding of each word that appears
in the context and we're trying to
predict
the reporting that follows or the once
said appending on your accounting and in
the middle of the W Maddox is
essentially given essentially giving
that the embeddings mother exists as the
dimensions of a vocabulary by Anwar and
then if dimensions dimensions were after
the other go around
skip gram weren't trying to predict
context given an award right so
everything in a sentence for killing
defining a context of say five words
were somewhere in the middle we're not
trying to predict all the other words
that most probably surround the world in
that context so no maths from that loss
function is essentially cross entropy so
yeah I won't spend too much time on that
anyway okay one year later globe comes
into play with this different approach
this is not like a probabilistic
language model neural net language model
approach but it's rather co-current
multics approach it's kind of like
similar to LSA flattened semantic
analysis so what they do is given a
corpus we built the co-current
smatterings of a given window context
window say 10 volts or something what
most of the times the mahdis is
symmetric in the sense that the world I
and the world J appear in the same
context so don't do like some extends
around that and then we're defining a
very weird objective function which
explained in a bit and by minimizing
that function were getting back our
representations or world the bendings
this is a session least installed with
irrigation book problem and we have the
X the X is the kalam smart right this
end by V by V word face the size of the
Cabrillo vocabulary we have two word
vectors and we discussed a little bit
about that we like to let left the right
context for the word die and the word
che and every single pass on on the
matrix there is a correction but follows
I mean just a post yet the Horta but
paper was really really hard to follow
or or the maths and people spent like
two or three years trying to decode why
we was working more or less same holds
with globe it's much much simpler much
more clear in the maths that implements
but there are some some assumptions that
are there just make it work and doesn't
feel completely right I mean all the
buildings are working but most of the
people don't know why there are some
heated externally because be discussing
that later so the Pennington and all are
also including the bias words the bias
terms in the objective function and
there is moving out frequent words with
the function f which essentially
suppressing stop words words to the pair
appear too many often on the training
set we're optimizing this function again
without a crowd a synchronous to
castigated and sent and eventually were
jetting but then brain thinks us like
the sum of the two world vectors I can
take like the left
context and the right context we do that
because at some point might be necessary
depending on the on the use case we we
might end up with not having a symmetric
co-occurrence matrix for some reason and
that will give us the ability to learn
different representations I mean wasn
double J's essentially like left around
colonists they're very very close and
there are only different because random
initialization is justified very well in
the in the paper and with some Hydra
parameters of a
a in next month which essentially used
to smooth the effect of very frequent
words followed that 2016 again we call
of some other people from which means no
word when I'm sorry
from from Facebook this time introducing
first to tell fast text which is
essentially an extension of work back
right and the idea is to and reads and
buy things with sub-goal deformation
this is massively useful for example in
scenarios where have expelled spellers
like in the steppes engine for example
you will just get similar words really
close in the embedding space because
you're essentially looking on their
plain engrams character level engrams
and the hypothesis that because it's
gonna be likely replacements or missing
characters telegrams could be very very
similar
so essentially what they are doing is
they're getting awards splitting the
world in anagrams learn the bindings
from the engrams and calculate the final
and binding as the sum of all the
engrams which is cool I worked like I
said it's a solid two hours of tea and
grandma medics and works pretty
particularly for cases we have expecting
errors or type of stuff like that okay
some months bucketing looks like an end
of 2017 facebook another facebook team
came up with a generalization of bedding
techniques which is they call it stuff
space this one is not only for for text
the Facebook page of the Facebook github
page of start space has examples for
link prediction graph inference graph
for medics and so on so forth it's and
essentially and any point in time you
can replace natural language processing
with any system that hosts
you can actually apply that on code you
can reply that and potentially music and
so on support as long as you have data
you don't care what the vocabulary is
we're using for example in Argos
embedding techniques to learn similarity
from Kingsland black work documents
essentially product goes viewed together
in a session by a user
say for example it works very very well
so stuff space stuff space generalizes
things a bit with with an optimization
objective which is consists of two
concrete parts the loss function per
bolts or the loss function can be either
hint-hint loss or soft mods and
similarity function we can which can be
cosine similarity or just dot product
and we're learning representations over
entities where we define in the Botsford
like the loss function we're giving it a
positive example so we're at the board X
and we're looking forward the world X
plus one so that can be like a positive
example and similar to to go to vague
and negative sampling we're just
generating a bunch of negative examples
post negative sampling one of the ways
to speed up the calculation of the
output layer and soft match in beam we
have millions or billions of words over
Valley is because it's to actually
sample words from the vocabulary so you
know in advance which word is correct
and instead of doing softmax in the
entire medium words the big factor
you're just sampling a small number of
them say 10 or 50 or 100 but it's an
approximation of course but works really
really well so this is like in the same
case in the same mentality will generate
it positive examples in the bonds of
negative examples for defining a loss
function that actually quantifies that
template in the numbering will
strengthen is to minimize the loss cool
okay bones round
run/walk this this is an awesome paper
these guys this is all right all these
guys are doing some serious work around
embeddings so people were asking white
distinct words right and there are
several interesting questions to pose
ironed out why essentially what's the
property of natural languages or any Co
currents model like distributional model
the terms words entities from distinct
representations to continuous
representations while maintaining their
similarity what we defined similarity
anyway that's a very good question the
second question is empirically it
appears that most of the models in
mainstream an Olympic tasks are working
better in moderate dimensions so I
should just train a model with
dimensionality of like say 500 we most
probably most of the time most people
from better compared to a model with
1,000 or even higher dimensions so I
think it's interest rate spot between
dimensionality and performance and
that's something that it's it's very
very interesting so these guys are
coming up with yet another embeddings
model where the model we approach the
problem with a generative model right so
what this says is like is okay say let's
imagine that we have like a unit vector
somewhere like in the vocabulary space
which points towards a direction the
direction is what's being discussed it
can be sports can be politics and so on
and so forth then next word like in the
sequence of the word is going to
generate is coming from sampling the
distribution of
the the x value of the dot product
between the discourse vector like the
random vector over the vocabulary right
so walls that are tend to be singular in
general would have higher probability to
be selected for example if you're
talking about sports say football and so
on all these goals are much more likely
to be up to appear as next course rather
than I don't know like you doughnuts you
most probably it's not so typical to
find neural Nets of optimization
functions in like in in the sports
article okay and with some mumbo jumbo
maths which I am not sure if although
they're ending up in cue objective
functions the first one is essentially
the frequency of like again the
co-occurrence matrix will essentially
they're mean they're learning the
factors free your via whatever with the
first objective function and given some
hyperparameters
c and so on and so forth and the second
optimization functions use pairwise
mutual information which is again
closely related to how water backwards
and that's yet another paper so pairwise
mutual information is essentially the
log of the probability of two worlds
appearing together by their product and
so on and so forth okay now say we have
the firm's like you have the embedding
model for choice and we want to build
features for our machine learning
algorithm how do we do that most
traditional machine learning algorithms
are working on fixed dimension
dimensions like logistic creation
support vector machines and so forth a
cool observation that comes again back
from Port avec is that insert contexts
of size say five just adding vectors
together works very well so say for
example you're trying to you help like a
you want to build a classifier for
metaphor detection we'll be discussing
that in a bit what you can do is detect
a verb in the sentence get the context
the left and right three words on the
left three words on the right get
representations then balance sum them up
and feed that are supposedly for
negative example in your model right
that's one thing that works in a sum or
average of any words in the context
there are several other nifty approaches
around that I also discovered one just
this morning it was on a previous talk
again come from Facebook it's jet
instead of getting like a denial average
so fine words get the average of a
unitary norm of the vectors that are
composing the sentence essentially the
problem relates to how to prepare cobia
computer how do we actually obtain
sentence and beddings right and again
aurora told the guys from rod will come
with very interesting approach so say
you have a document and you won't have
document
bindings you compute the impendence by
getting all the words that compose the
document as a weight weighted sum of the
probabilities in the corpus different
worlds of different frequencies in the
corpus for you latest matrix take the
first principal component then you have
your bindings and this is war - Grady
really well it also follows the random
walk approach again this is like a
little bit heavy non on math
implementations there not to pass or
divert the links for the implementations
for Tyvek is on google site glove comes
from Stanford fast X and stuff space are
coming from Facebook elicits Broadwalk
there is no implementation yet but we've
been working on that and most probably
the next fall in a month through eBay
and limitation and Python for that as
well
in Python most probably all know Jensen
which I know some tools for topic
modeling and and bindings in general
implements what vac and also dr. vac
which is essentially an extension of
portal back were along with the text
you're also including the labels or
metadata that surrounds us so you say
for example you have like or I don't
know you have text and you have also
labels like sentiment your loving
sentimental presentation or tag
representation and it can be very very
useful in some cases and also there's an
very very nice implementation github
from machine block Python which is
essentially getting the implementation
of glow and turned to Python site and
permutation which works really any way
no application applications in NLP
better for detection there's a paper
following up on that will be actually
presented at some point like in the next
couple of weeks of some research we've
been doing with some colleagues and
friends down University of Athens
wouldn't be doing is label something
like 2,000 sentences with some of them
as metaphors 50/50 like a ratio and the
other et al train the model in the
corpus of quick text of something like
30 million rewards or something then
were locating the verb in the sentence
would get in the context to the right
yet representations and use that as
pictures for our model
and that works with very very high
accuracy comparing to other about
surfing would have protein or something
like 78% of accuracy which is in better
for detection something really hard it's
like very very good result same
structure also on circumspection circle
is yet more difficult metaphor so
results are looking promising but not as
good yet and there is another approach
from another work balancing margarine
newsroom and you're tagging curating
texts like articles and you need to
somehow grant all reject articles based
on the propensity to be good or like
high quality journalism a journalistic
pieces so jet or all the already
approved articles along with all the
capital tools get their document
representations with many of the
techniques discussed reversely fit that
to machine learning model and get a
probability of enough of a new article
to be to be good to be good or likely to
approved so that's very interesting
again research in progress at the moment
oh there's sucks so I'll change it
there's another jet application
most probably have you ever worked with
recurrent like a sequence two seconds or
RNN models so yeah you know that the NAB
and there is an abandoned layer that one
common way to do is just let your model
care a spy thoughts to train it based on
your corpus but if you already have a
pre trained model or can get a trained
model what you can do is say for example
download a glove model or a quarterback
model load the weights for all the words
in the vocabulary pass the weights in
your a Patek model and prevent prevent
it from training like make it not
trainable so that will be something like
something like that will have the
embedded layer and instead they were
fixing the weights calculated loaded
from an existing break system download
it
model collect transfer learn the
scenario and making not trainable so the
the optimization process won't spend
time trying to optimize the weights on
that layer and that's also very cool to
have like complex sequence the sequence
models you can save lots of time and
especially if you have like a model
trained on Wikipedia most probably
whatever your model is it won't be as
good as a model you get from Wikipedia
and thanks very much
[Applause]
questions so if the different embedding
models you talked about do you have any
preference as to when you use which I
think it's part of like of my grid
search which works best for metaphor
detection what work seems to be working
much much better
don't go like in terms of like almost
50% like higher inaccuracy I'm not sure
why write this work to be done there for
things like trying to find which what
the user record means when they're doing
a search query fostex this is awesome
because essentially can get similarities
of like misspelled world typos and so on
so on and so forth and there is also a
parameter of running time so globe is
much faster as long as you have the Eco
currents multix tokens matrix can take
some time to bathe but then on the other
hand you can just created ons with a
specific like you know like cutoff
window what to be appearing at least 100
times in the course and so on and so
forth store it and then I create many
models all those relations in there to
to support versus want with the
co-occurrence matrix the other arms
train the model on the Turkish matrix
thank you any more questions oh this to
what extent to LST M models fit into the
this all the other models that you
mentioned it
sorry to what extent do you LS T M
models long short mm-hmm term models is
that embedded in some of this
information or is that completely a
separate model if I get your questions
right is like how the model performs
with that or how do we
actually black betting's pre-training
the beddings on LSD ends the first one
yeah how like the model come back
performs against its application
dependent I guess so it's trial and
error that are there it's like hi
nonlinearities nonlinearities so
reasoning about why a model is better
than the other Frank I don't know um
thank you for that for the talk it's in
R and walk the discourse vector C sort
of similar to the center loss and it's
something okay how do you initialize
that discourse
Oh initially you initialize it randomly
essentially so it's pointers time you're
pointing towards their action they're
sampling words based on that direction
and then you're displacing the vector a
little bit and carry on and with some
maths that followed you can good Kimmy
can make a center point yeah it's crimp
like a like a pointer pointing to what's
being discussed and then we'll follow up
with the objective function minimize
that to get in the appendix it's kind of
like things don't work and what but I
think can be safely classified as energy
models okay
and then just better taking the question
so you mentioned 200 and 300 as
embedding sizes that are reasonable for
a glove for words what happens with
articles and you know embedding
sentences and articles are they the same
sort of my piece is actually mining
writing style so it works amazingly well
with the normed average up to the point
that if I have say a user with the same
less than roughly 500 tweets and split
in split the tweets into what I'll be
getting back to factors that are almost
identical so seems to be work really
well she really depends on the style of
the document right for different levels
of complexity of vocabulary and so on
and so forth that heavily effects of
course the output because you're
planning towards in all possible ways
but style matters like the stylist in
choices for fear of the observable area
as a generating text process and if we
have time for a few more questions
thanks back to the top very interesting
by the way you mentioned document
embeddings how do you document
representations compared in terms of
performance and interpretability
to something like topic modeling with
Lda I haven't done the cabarrus ins for
some problems where essentially we want
you essentially compare entities in
general where entities has essentially
sets of words like sentences documents
and so forth there are several
techniques some of them work with
similar to the previous question work
really really well
on
Pacific problems others don't work that
well for example short sentence
representations seem to be working
really really well on metaphor detection
because essentially we'll learn a
statistical test we just get like all
the sentences we have tagged metaphor
metaphor and literal there is a very
interesting property that the average
distance on between verb and object in
metaphors is much higher than the
average distance in literal us they're
marked in the veneks model which
translate again some various values
parenting linguistics theories that as
humans were essentially when we are
doing metaphor with trying to localize
to three dimensions metaphors she was
just clicking like put in space and time
essential okay so it's something like
man were walk work better for like a
topic for example month club like a
implementation Latino okay thanks thanks
wow that was a great talk great
questions Costas less give a hand to
Kostas
you